yeah liquor girls you know how I became
a little girl oh you're hot you could
dance hardly hard well I could dance
um
this was fun a fun story again not the
obvious choice I used to teach dance in
cheerleading camps once teenager and
some of the girls that were on staff
with me 17 17 years old
these beautiful five foot seven you know
the figure for days blonde hair blue
eyes
they come they go hey Polly do you want
to try out to be a Laker girl with us
and I'd look up at them I go no like why
not
because I'm I don't look like you and I
don't fit the mold but you're so good
Paula come on what do you have to lose
and that was a challenge Miss nothing I
suppose and uh four girls picked me up
we carpooled all the way to the none of
them got it you got it well no but
you had to be 18 I was 17 and a half
okay so I remember when we got down
there I bought a dance bag with me and I
noticed the other girls didn't they just
had their leotards and we were walking
in and I was number we were in the 700s
they were close to 2 000 girls and
they'd line up a hundred at a time at
the Forum
and I was subbing at 742 and the other
four girls were relatively around that
number with me and I remember on my toes
and I'm I'm hitting my hips and they go
okay if we call your number please step
forward
and numbers are being called and then
two of my friends like one after another
got called and I'm going and I'm like
yeah like that and then my numbers
called
and the other two girls weren't called
and I'm just going oh my God and I'm on
my tip toes they go uh state your name I
go Paula Abdul spell it abdull by Kareem
Abdul-Jabbar
sure whatever
they go how tall are you I go five foot
two
I'm five but nothing
so lie lie lie lie
but
this is the coolest part I think we're
going to be able to dance and move
forward and the rest are gonna be cut
you hear the voice from God going all
right ladies we have to thin the herd if
we called your number thank you for
coming down come back next season and
try out wait you were the guys the girls
that weren't weren't didn't even get to
dance okay
I'm like going I can't believe I didn't
even get to dance aren't you guys pissed
that now three of us were cut two girls
so the the two girls I thought were
being cut they're left and I just go
I'll be right back I went into the
bathroom because no I had a plan I
certainly did I put on a different
leotard
I put I got a different number I had my
hair down so now let me let me put it in
a ponytail and I entered as my middle
name Julie you cheater and I spelled my
last name a-b-a-l
funniest thing is there's there was a
guy that actually saw me do this and I'm
going how in the hell can one person
hone in looking at me and laughing and I
went out of the bathroom and the two
girls that were cut with me they're like
you can't do it I went by and I ran out
onto the form floor right up to my two
friends were there and they're all
they're negotiating
can't do that Paula this this is against
the rules I go
my dad taught me if it's not written in
the rules there are no rules
right so I I entered as my middle name
Julie Abel new number put my hair in a
ponytail
I got to dance and all three of us got
cut so now all five of us are done Gonzo
and all that they're pissed off is that
the two girls that originally got cut
are mad at me now the other two girls
are they're mad at me and I'm going
aren't you mad that we got cut and I
said guys please can you just wait one
more round I still have one more outfit
no come on I'm not kidding I'm not
kidding did you did you know this she
changed into another effing out but I
saved the best for last what did you put
on well first of all I said can you wait
and they said hell no you can take a
taxi or a bus and I went really like a
really and I went okay I went back into
the stall this time I saved the best for
last night the old Jane Fonda red and
white chevron stripe leotards
blue leg warmers oh no I don't you were
17 I don't want to see pictures
yeah
um wristbands and now I had a headband
like Olivia Newton John and I'm like
okay dear God please I gotta get this I
gotta become a Laker girl I gotta I got
it proved to my dad like as if this is
gonna make my career little did I know
uh I ran out there and as I was running
out of the bathroom
I entered
my first initial p
my middle initial J I spelled my last
name Apple apply
Paula Julie apple and what am I going to
do with my hair I've worn it down I put
it in a ponytail
I'm gonna put half up and half down with
a hair scrunchie I started the worst
hair craze ever the half up half down
palm tree on the head it all started as
me trying to figure out how it could
look different to be a Lego girl got a
different number as I ran out of the
bathroom I heard back half of the Arena
come forward and the front half go back
and it was perfect I just ran to the
front in the middle
this guy is still laughing at me a gun
guy who ended up being an intern from
UCLA who got their job of of being in
charge of the Laker Girls
his name was Lon Rosen I know Ron Lon
Rosen was my first boss when I swear to
God I know long he's a good guy to know
he got me a Dodger tickets yes because
he's been he's been in the business
as her intern then stuck with magic
became his agent his manager like and
and has everything to do with the
Dodgers and it's just crazy so
I got to dance
and then I heard front half of the Arena
go back and back half go front and at
that moment I'm pivoting I'm gonna I'm
going they're gonna forget about me God
damn they're gonna forget about me and I
said I promise to God I'd be bold and
daring and I literally turned around and
I ran back squirmed my way to the front
and center and Lon was laughing
and uh that's how I made it I got the
third attempt you
I mean and I became the tenacity but
that's